la musique a résonné pendant trois jours
sur l'île aumône à mantes-la-jolie les
halls factory festival revenait pour une
deuxième édition
un premier rendez vous festif pour
beaucoup après le confinement est en
pleine crise sanitaire
c'est que ça fait du bien de retrouver
un peu de monde un peu de musique
après ses tanks étaient un peu
difficiles c'est vraiment un plaisir
bon c'est assez rassurant on voit tombe
respecte le port du masque
le site est très agréable à écouter un
très bon concert un moment on est
vraiment ravi d'être sur cette île
un événement qui a dû s'adapter au
contexte épidémique masque obligatoire à
l'intérieur du village spectateurs assis
les jauges d'entrée limiter les
organisateurs ont dû faire face
également à des déprogrammations mais le
festival a pu bien se tenir
un grand bonheur un grand bonheur pour
les organisateurs parce qu'on a beaucoup
travaillé pour le public parce qu'il est
en manque de manifestations culturelles
et puis pour les artistes et interprètes
parce que ils ont quasiment pas eu
l'occasion et la possibilité de se
produire depuis des mois et encore moins
devant un public une programmation
éclectique avec à l'honneur les
instruments à vent dont le manteau est
un territoire référence pour leur
fabrication
ce samedi soir les festivaliers avaient
rendez vous avec la musique des antilles
de jacob desvarieux
le cofondateur de kassav se produisait
avec ses amis dont mario canonge au
piano une première scène pour lui depuis
son confinement en guadeloupe pendant
six mois
ben on jouait pour notre téléphone ans
filmé en train de jouer ou juste comme
ça quoi
c'est mieux qu'il ya des gens ça aussi
c'est compliqué c'est de jouer et de
voir que il ya peu de gens alors sont
pas venus ici la banque à la raison ceux
qui sont venus en 3d est très motivé le
festival et aux factures il a accueilli
2700 personnes pour cette deuxième
édition le rendez vous devrait revenir
une nouvelle fois l'année prochaine à
mantes la jolie
[Applaudissements]